the 15 players from the challenge meet
twice a week next to cartoons Airport
Sarah Edward is the trainer and the
captain of the team
Edward is a Christian and had to do a
lot of lobbying to get permission for
the women to play football here it's not
written in the Holy Quran that because
they are not they suffer so after that
they allow us to play but in indoor
place not outdoor they train outside
anyway because for the past two years
using the indoor soccer facilities has
cost money about twenty eight euros an
hour which is much too expensive for the
team it's not easy for women to play
football in Sudan Sarah Edward has
already lost many players for whom that
was too much of a challenge there are
only a few teams and hardly any trainers
Sarah Edward wants to change that most
of my team now African see licensed from
Africa so my plan is after maybe one
year two years that I want them to have
their own teams
in Sudan's Muslim society women who go
out in public without a veil are frowned
upon there's low acceptance of women
doing sports in general let alone
playing soccer which is considered a
man's sport
none glad ron has been playing soccer in
the challenge team for two years the 32
year old lives at home in Khartoum City
Limits she went to university but can't
find work
soccer is her passion but her parents
don't want her to play another problem
my face is on the streets while using
public transport or in crowded areas
sometimes we get harassed and ridiculed
during practice and inside the football
courts by spectators since there are so
few women's teams the challenge also
play against men the to lunch played
well and won this match they received no
assistance from the Sudanese soccer
Authority even though FIFA has allocated
money for it
[Applause]
but still Sarah Edward can celebrate a
small victory
the team has once again been permitted
to practice on the association soccer
pitch and these female soccer players
hope that one day they will get regular
support for their team